I don't want to watch any do you watch
your standup I listen to it I recorded
and I listened to it and every single
one at the Comedy Store I do like the
night I saw you I listened to every
single one on the way home to see what I
did I got to start doing that well I
mean what do you mean how do you how do
you gauge whether or not like just in
the moment I remember say that again try
to remember to say that next time
because that was good or you know I've
been doing lately if I say something on
stage that works and you all I'm gonna
remember it but you never do you know
like in the moment you say it I say hey
can you guys tweet that at me later and
I make them feel something like that's
the first time you that I've ever said
that and that was fun I'll be in my
Netflix special but you got to tweet it
at me later and then you have people
tweeting you notes
Wow so you put him to work you have the
audience that's unheard of they love it
it's interactive
I mean what does that feel like to
perform for Madison Square but going
from Newport Kentucky what's the
difference honestly what is the
difference between performing for like
300 people and I don't how many is
Madison Square Garden 90 I don't know
you know I've had this on the calendar
for six months now but and looking at it
on and off I haven't really paid much
attention to it until this week it's all
kind of hitting me
yeah the promo for and I'm like wow I
got you know four shows to do this
weekend so I don't think it's gonna hit
me until I go to the building see the
stage and all that stuff but once you're
out there yeah it's the build it's it's
not exactly when you're on stage I feel
fine it's getting to the stage that's
does it ever worry you that like you're
gonna like where is there to go from
Madison Square Garden we've talked about
that my matter giant we're just talking
about like like you don't want to like
top that or like so you know I don't
know if it's it's just one of these
moments in your career where you do it
and then whatever happens happens it's
not like I'm planning some big scheme
like we're gonna do something so grand
sure it's you know we never planned on
doing for for Madison Square Gardens to
begin with I mean it's it's nuts and
it's I'm so happy for you because like I
said met you early on and you were just
not only so funny but just a good a good
guy and you wrote it you wrote a book us
you wrote a book lash I mean the Sam I
saw you he was promoting stuff was here
not so long ago I mean you've been a
crazy or you have a 20 month old is that
true to be a little daughter and we have
a son on the way on the way oh my god
yeah very exciting personal life as well
my wife is just fantastic I mean you
know no how did you as me will you bring
me hope because I watch your I watch
when you take vid
of your wife on I'm obsessed with her by
the way she's so hot she's so cute she's
just like I'm just like I love her I've
like texted videos of you two
girlfriends being like because we just
like appreciate when a girl is just
perfect and cute and we're just like
I've I'm obsessed with your wife I think
she's awesome happy to hear that well
you found a good one and she found a
good one but tell me how you guys met
how do you my personal trainer I had
asked my personal trainer at the time I
said you got any hot chicks you uh
training yeah 6:00 a.m. she comes in I
go out that's really early I said
scheduled me at 7:00 I want to see what
you got and sure enough I'm like wow
she's really cute and I started hitting
on her now she's from the south she's
from Memphis Tennessee she's a
sweetheart she's you know just loves
everybody and everything very positive
yeah and I'm like I'm coming to the gym
like dawn up like the first day this is
like like your do keep scheduling the
seven o'clock I try and start peppering
me around her but I'm getting ready to
go to the gym like I'm showering baby
oil the whole thing spray tan two days
before right get it just right but she
has no idea I'm hitting on her she's
like you know kind of clueless about
like life in general like oh he's just a
nice guy
and finally we went out and she was like
a mute she didn't speak I'm like geez I
mean is this Girl Talk so it took a
while for her to kind of warm up and
once she did it was you know we were
kind of off to the races wait why didn't
she speak the first she knew I was a
comedian and she didn't want to like say
anything that could possibly be part of
my act she knew I was kind of you know
observational and my humor and
judgmental and whatnot so she didn't
want to like say anything she's kind of
like nervous yeah and
and then after a while she I can't get
it a shut up no that makes like I hear
that and I go I need to shut up more
it's so alluring with women just like
don't have to ever go off when you go
out
are you the talker yeah on the date yeah
I need to shut up
I really do it really oh yeah very
inquisitive I don't want to talk I'm not
talking about myself as much as yeah I
ask a lot of I find that I get guys to
open up more and then I'm like do you
want to know anything about me and I get
interview them more I don't know I'm I
met a point my life where I'm going
after the wrong person you know when
you're attracted to the wrong person
you're like I hope this doesn't work out
because this is a bad person so this the
spray tan yeah it's just the right guy
no he was one of the war my worst
choices ever but you're revisiting it
well he rejected me and I refuse to let
that be our stories so I want to kind of
get it I don't want to get him back but
I just want him to know that he made a
bad choice okay because I'm so like if
you don't love me at my pay list you're
not gonna love me so why am I even
trying like it's just I mean but I'll
you know what I took from that what you
said is that you got to put it out there
that you want to meet someone you got to
talk to your trainer you got to say hey
I'm open to this set me up you got any
hot ladies coming in at 6 a.m. yeah do
you do the internet no because I feel
like a minute I met a Fame level and I
don't think of famous at all but I'm
just I think that if you were interested
in me you know where to find me
and if you don't know who I am then we
don't have a lot in common then you
don't like comedy and then I don't want
to really date you anyway you don't mean
no okay so like I don't expect people to
know who I am but I expect you to
underlie to eventually come across me if
if you if we are interested in the same
things which is I like comedy and and
good funny things you're gonna maybe
know I exist at some point so if you
then you'll probably hear me talk about
being single and then you'll probably
know that you can easily just slide into
my DMS on Instagram and get my attention
just make your profile picture a little
bit bigger than you would maybe like to
have it so that I don't have to
screenshot the message that you send and
then blow up your tiny microscopic photo
to see if I would date you or even worse
have your account on private so then I
have to friend you and then when I don't
like the way you look I have to unfriend
you and you know that's exactly why I
unfriended you it's gross so much going
on I mean for you to be doing
screenshots zoom is this spray tans and
screenshots
that's the name of my book
you